tu as recruté la moitié des hommes à Boston que
penses-tu que leurs familles pensent de
moi la seule raison pour laquelle ils ne jettent pas des
choses et ne me crachent pas parce que tu es si
populaire que je ne peux pas me concentrer sur
la loi commerciale britannique Je m'en fiche
à propos du droit commercial britannique, je ne voudrais peut-être
même pas être avocat, c'est une
profession solide et utile, oui et je
veux être utile, mais maintenant pas ensuite
n'importe où et puis les choses mr.  Slade, ils
ne vont jamais bien, la femme vous aura
là où je suis ne pense pas que votre affaire et
c'est votre tactique préférée à utiliser, vous
ne me direz pas non mais la guerre sera
terminée dans un mois